And that's just the beginning of what you can
do with MapReduce. Recommendation systems,
fraud detection, item classification are
all great problems for MapReduce. These all have some
basic characteristics in common. They have a lot of data,
and the work can be parallelized rather than slogging
through in serial. Perhaps one of the more difficult things
to learn when you're new to Hadoop. Is how to
think about solving problems in terms of MapReduce. It can
be very different than how you're used to working. And
frankly, it takes a lot of practice. So in the next
lesson, we're going to write the code for the sales by
store problem, and we'll also start talking about other MapReduce problems.